de pressing question did Taylor Swift
leave in a
box what's in the box Taylor Swift fans
are speculating she snuck out of Travis
Kelsey's suite at Arrowhead Stadium in a
humaniz metal popcorn container to avoid
the paparazzi watch she's in that just
like her that's her is she in there
she's in there like her like her
cleaning
supplies
that's her you guys it's like the broom
thing that was
her do you know how they you know how
they pop her that was her that's
her that's all the confirmation I
need now who knows if she actually was
in there but it's not odd for famous
people to travel in discreet ways here's
Brian kilme getting picked up for
work oh my God
[Music]
and here's Joy bear leaving the set of
the
[Applause]
view all right Kelly do you think she
was in the Box this is how she this is
how she rolls right for some sometimes
in concerts and stuff well yeah that
that's where the speculation is coming
from that she used one of these you know
Contraptions to change during her
concert but absolutely not this girl was
not trying to hide this to me my hot
take this was all a PR move okay she is
up in the Box screaming for Kelsey when
he gets his touchdown she's next to Mama
Kelsey right she has a movie coming out
the erors tour right she wants a lot of
positive press she also wants us all to
forget her most recent shocking romance
that caused a lot of stir and I mean
Kelsey he's that like homegrown you know
Golden Boy I honestly don't remember his
name because I'm noty or was that
somebody else it was it was some a
Neo-Nazi they were accused of oh really
yes and so a lot of her fans were very
upset was it the guy in Canada the old
dude that's a she has dated the Gambit
Hy yes yes she doesn't age is just a
number to her you know
uh Brian usually Joe Biden travels in a
box but it's called a coffin right uh I
will say this I mean it's will you say
this it's a solid Theory it's a solid
theory that she's in the Box because the
popcorn's on top and the one way it's on
the inside but there's other thing that
are in sweets uh there's this thing
called an elevator that brings you right
down to the locker room a lot of people
think they would use this thing the
elevator that gives you total silence
and as you said Kelly she wasn't trying
to hide it she's sitting in front acting
like a 40-10 game was the best thing
ever in week four of the NFL season
winning a game they were going to win
before they snapped the first ball and
kicked it or kicked it off so and he
gets a touchdown inconsequential
touchdown from three yards out and she
has never seen anything like it in her
life but I'm glad she was there yeah you
know uh Emily to your
point how long will this relationship
last before she's writing like Angry
songs about football players oh I I
honestly don't hair but I will say that
as someone with extensive knowledge of
stadiums in the NFL I actually think she
was in the Box here's why because this
is coming against the landscape of me
not knowing anything about her not being
a fan whatever but a apparently it
happens all the time B to your point
about the elevator usually elevators are
to a group of Suites not the actual
Suite unless the chief's Arrowhead
Stadium is built differently than every
other one I've been in you know what I
mean the elevators are only reserved for
that area C when she was picked up on
video walking with with Travis at the
bottom before they got in the car she
like disappeared in between being next
to his mom and then being down next to
him below so how did she get from A to B
I point C and what about D exactly so I
think that's exactly what happened David
Copperfield style I think she actually
was in the box I think you convinced
everybody in America I am so confused
and we're learning the alphabet I am so
confused Joe uh you actually enter
comedy clubs like that so the audience
won't leave well that's oh that is I
know was isn't that cruel I'm sorry Joe
that hurt that hurt they they actually
sneak me inside a roasted boar and I eat
my way
out but can you can you imagine like
thinking that it's good press to like
disguise yourself it's a locker full of
popcorn like if I opened that up and
thinking I was going to get popcorn and
it was Taylor Swift I would be insane
right there the red wouldn't be the
jerseys of that football team um but
where's my popcorn yeah and the other
thing too is like it's like if you have
to travel around inside popcorn bins is
Fame really worth it like what's the
rest of your night going to be like you
go in a convertible with a football
player and have sex that doesn't sound
appetizing at
all well at least she got out in a jiffy
right a little humor for the kids out
there all right up next a guy with a
Greek God's physique calls actors wimpy
and weak hey Sean hanity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else